which fast and furious film almost
destroyed the entire franchise because
it didn't have enough stars keep
watching to find out about the most
disastrous sequels in history
for a solid decade from 2002 to 2012
will smith could do no wrong at the box
office smith did it largely without
relying on sequels headlining 10 hits
that were star vehicles including risky
big budget movies like irobot and
hancock however smith's butts in seats
drawing power started to slide with
2013's after earth when most movie stars
careers start to slide they hit the
panic button and go back to the
franchises that made them famous in the
first place and sure enough smith went
back for a third bad boys film in 2020
but as a movie star he really got his
start with independence day a 1996
surprise hit that brought in 817 million
dollars worldwide so why wouldn't smith
star in its 2016 sequel independent
state resurgence according to smith he
wanted to do suicide squad instead so
fox plowed ahead with the sequel without
their biggest star even if actors like
jeff goldblum and bill pullman did
return the film bombed with 384 million
dollars worldwide on a 165 million
dollar budget while suicide squad nearly
doubled that with 746 million dollars
worldwide as it turns out moviegoers
didn't just want to see evil aliens they
wanted to see will smith punching them
a common cliche in movie fan culture is
nobody cares about the humans in a
monster movie so nobody cared about
ripley and alien or andaro and king kong
yes you go to a monster movie for the
monsters but you care about it because
of the characters a good case in point
is 2014's godzilla godzilla's trailer
was one of the best of the past 20 years
headlining a marketing campaign that put
brian cranston front and center now
cranston isn't necessarily an a-list
movie star but in 2014 he was just
coming off his career defining work and
breaking bad so his presence lent
godzilla's serious credibility however
while cranston was marketed as the lead
he was killed off in the first half hour
as a result cranston wasn't in godzilla
king of the monsters at all
without any clear connection to the
forgettable 2014 film godzilla king of
the monsters opened to a tepid 47
million dollars and ended its run with
383 million dollars worldwide on a 170
million dollar budget not a bomb but
definitely a disappointment compared to
the originals 529 million dollars the
lack of cranston wasn't the cause but a
symptom moviegoers do care about humans
and monster movies
there are some movie stars that
audiences simply enjoy watching in
special effects movies jim carrey is
different he has his own special effect
so making sequels to jim carrey movies
without jim carrey may be the most
nonsensical thing ever yet it happened
not once not twice but thrice
dumb and dumber when harry met lloyd in
2003 son of the mask in 2005 and evan
almighty in 2007. why no carrie he
doesn't like sequels and if these were
the scripts he was being offered it's
easy to see why dumb and dumber face
planet first earning 28 million dollars
worldwide on a 30 million dollar budget
you would think such a performance would
put the brakes on son of the mask and
evan almighty but surprisingly son of
the mask followed with jaime kennedy in
the lead earning 59 million dollars
worldwide on a mind-boggling 100 million
dollar budget then evan almighty came
out with universal spending an
incredible 175 million dollars on the
steep corral vehicle to earn back
174 million dollars when the smoke
cleared the studio had spent more than
double the bruce almighty budget on a
jim carrey sequel without jim carrey
that just defies explanation do you want
to explain yourself congressman what is
going on
oh
these
are birds
ghostbusters was a genuine cultural
sensation in 1984 and while the film's
1989 sequel isn't well regarded it was
still a huge deal earning 215 million
dollars worldwide
then the franchise went dormant for 27
years until it was rebooted in 2016.
this reboot was simply called
ghostbusters but many folks referred to
it as some variation of the girl
ghostbusters movie because it had female
leads with bill murray dan aykroyd and
ernie hudson only appearing in brief
torch passing cameos but moviegoers who
waited decades for another sequel didn't
want to see any torches being passed
they wanted the originals it also
probably didn't help that online chatter
in the months leading up to the film
revolved around dumb petty arguments
about whether women could or should be
ghostbusters it's rarely a good sign
when instead of talking about how
excited people are to see your upcoming
movie they're angrily debating such
nonsense
ultimately despite the star power of
kristen wiig melissa mccarthy and kate
mckinnon the film closed with 229
million dollars worldwide 67 million
dollars less than ghostbusters 32 years
earlier while many blamed sexism for the
movie's failure another possible culprit
was making a ghostbusters movie without
the original ghostbusters
we came we saw we kicked its ass
harrison ford's box office earnings are
5.2 billion dollars domestically and 10
billion dollars worldwide one of his
many hits was 1993's the fugitive which
earned 183 million dollars domestically
and 353 million dollars worldwide
finishing third at the year-end box
office while tommy lee jones won an
oscar for his role as u.s marshal samuel
gerard it was ford who put the butts in
seats so perhaps u.s marshals a sequel
to the fugitive focused on gerrard was
doomed from the get-go because it lacked
the key ingredient to the original's
popularity harrison ford the film did
add in wesley snipes on robert downey jr
but marshalls failed to find an audience
earning 57 million on a 60 million
dollar budget in 1998.
while it doesn't seem like ford should
have played the titular fugitive again
it does seem clear that u.s marshals
probably shouldn't have been made in the
first place
in 1997 will smith and tommy lee jones
combine their star power with men in
black which earned 587 million dollars
worldwide and while too many black
sequels failed to reach the same pop
culture heights both made a lot of money
men in black 3 actually made more
worldwide thanks to the benefit to 15
years of inflation and a bigger
international market in 2019 though sony
pictures tried to reboot the franchise
without smith or jones replacing them
instead with chris hemsworth and tessa
thompson men in black international
closed with 80 million domestically and
253 million dollars worldwide 188
million dollars less than the previous
franchise low men in black 2 earned way
back in 2002. thanks to a modest 110
million dollar budget men in black
international probably squeaked by with
a small profit but the writing was on
the wall no smith no jones no audience
the fast and the furious franchise has
been a wild ride on screen and behind
the scenes as well the franchise went
from popular and profitable in the early
2000s to a billion dollar blockbuster
franchise in the 2010s all while
charting the character's perfectly
natural progression from la street
racers to international super spys the
fast and furious franchise does have one
black sheep however 2006's the fast and
the furious tokyo drift where this
prequel
sequel
spin-off fits into the overarching
furious timeline is a topic for debate
among fans but this much is clear it
crashed badly on a 85 million budget
tokyo drift earned only 62 million
dollars domestically and 157 million
dollars worldwide the impetus seems
clear it starred none of the original
cast largely because stars like vin
diesel and paul walker left and were
building their careers elsewhere drift
nearly killed the franchise but a
closing scene cameo from diesel gave
hope for a return so universal got the
band back together for 2009's fast and
furious saving the series and adding
billions of dollars to their bank
account the key takeaway you can't break
up the family
it's one thing to make a sequel without
the original cast but without the
central premise it'd be like making a
jaws sequel without a shark enter
halloween three halloween invented the
modern slasher film in 1978 putting a
face to the invisible killer of 1974's
black christmas with a charismatic uber
batting named michael myers perhaps just
as critical as jamie lee curtis as
scream queen lori strode and donald
pleasance as michael's haunted hunter
sam loomis together the trio propelled
the original halloween to 70 million
dollars worldwide on a 325 thousand
dollar budget while the 25 million
dollars of 1981's halloween 2 was a big
drop off on a 2.5 million dollar budget
it did just fine but when series
creators john carpenter and deborah hill
were asked to put together a third film
they agreed to participate only if the
halloween name would be used as more of
an anthology title with myers being
dropped instead halloween 3 season of
the witch is about an evil conglomerate
that turns kids heads into bugs when
they wear a mask and watch a tv show
while witch made money 14 million on a
2.5 million dollar budget in 1982 it was
such a departure that the series took a
time out for six years by 1988 michael
myers was back and he has been ever
since it should be mentioned however
that despite season of the witch
underperforming at the box office it has
gone on to become a creepy cult favorite
in no small part because of its ominous
london bridge is falling down inspired
jingle from the silver shamrock
halloween mask commercial
despite its b-movie title paul
verhoeven's sci-fi satire robocop earned
53 million dollars worldwide in 1987 as
well as a reputation for being one of
the best action movies of the 1980s a
big reason was the man wearing the robot
suit peter weller weller came back for
robocop 2 which earned 45 million
dollars in 1990 but was over the
franchise by the third film in 1993 as
it turns out moviegoers were too with
robert john burke stepping into the suit
robocop 3 bombed with a dreadful 10
million dollars worldwide this is
despite or maybe because of robocop 3
being rated pg-13 not r like the first
two presumably because the filmmakers
wanted to expand the potential audience
so much for that while it's unfair to
blame the robocop 3 failure on burke
replacing weller it's hard to deny that
the drop between the first two films and
the third both in quality and box office
was gigantic
i'd buy that for a dollar
the terminator made stars out of
filmmaker james cameron and actor arnold
schwarzenegger terminator 2 judgement
day made them icons hollywood has been
trying to recapture the magic again and
again and again ever since the
terminator was an out of nowhere sleeper
hits in 1984 earning 78 million dollars
worldwide on a 6 million dollar budget
terminator 2 took a 100 million dollar
budget and turned it into a 515 million
dollar blockbuster beating even disney's
beauty and the bees to top the year-end
box office charts in hindsight maybe the
franchise should have thrown in the
towel at that but there was more money
to be made if only the studio could
figure out how
after the mild success of 2003's rise of
the machines warner brothers tried to
relaunch the franchise without arnold at
all in 2009 for terminator salvation
investing a bafflingly high 200 million
dollars in the sequel and the most
memorable thing to come out of it was
the controversy over christian bale
screaming at a crew member during
filming the movie bombed with 125
million dollars domestic and 365 million
dollars worldwide by 2015's terminator
genesis not even arnold could save the
franchise while terminator dark fade
tanked worldwide despite reuniting
arnold linda hamilton and producer james
cameron hasta la vista baby
if peak 1980's arnold schwarzenegger
battling a seven foot tall killer alien
gets your blood pumping well you're not
alone moviegoers didn't get to choppa
but they did flock to the theater in
1987 to see predator on an 18 million
budget predator earned 59 million
domestically and 98 million dollars
worldwide however rather than become the
predator franchise's lieutenant alan
ripley schwarzenegger opted out of the
film's sequel so who would take his
place stallone van damme gibson nope
danny glover look glover's a fine actor
and was great in the lethal weapon
franchise but he wasn't quite a credible
replacement for schwarzenegger despite
nearly doubling the originals budget to
35 million dollars predator 2 managed a
minuscule 28 million domestically and 54
million dollars worldwide ouch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you